"We went by bicycle,
no automobile available
"because of wartime
restrictions on their use.
"On the way home, my
condition began to assume
"threatening forms.
"Everything in my field of
vision wavered and was distorted
"as I've seen in a curved mirror.
"I also had the sensation
"of being unable to move from the spot.
"Nevertheless, my assistant later told me
"that we had traveled very rapidly."
From the diary of Albert
Hoffman, Swiss chemist, 1943.
Switzerland has long been obsessed
with the science of the mind.
Take Albert Hoffman.
He was the first person to synthesize LSD.
On April 19th, 1943, he
ingested a tiny amount,
hopped on his bike
and then realized that all
matter is merely energy
condensed to a slow vibration,
there is no such thing as death,
and we are the imagination of ourselves.
Today Swiss labs and medical companies
are still pushing the frontiers
of our understanding of the mind.
There's less blotter involved,
but they're very much turned
on and tuned in to a unique mix
of neuroscience, computers and AI.
The research can be dazzling.
It can sometimes feel like
you need an IQ of 1000
to understand it,
but more and more I'm seeing
that we're on the cusp of things
that used to be called miracles.
And now you're going to
turn on the stimulation
and he'll do a leg extension.
And up, the stim is on now.
How does it feel when
it turns on like that?
It's fantastic.
Six years ago, Michele
here was in an accident
that left him unable to
move his legs at all.
Then he had electrodes
implanted on his spine,
and well, check him out.
He's one of the first
patients treated by Onward,
which has created a technology
to help reconnect
paralyzed people's brains
with their bodies.
The idea comes from a brain surgeon
and a neuroscientist Jocelyne
Bloch and Grégoire Courtine.
Several years ago, Grégoire
was studying paralyzed rats
at UCLA and came up with a way
to get their legs moving again.
So very simple approach at the beginning,
stimulating the spinal cord electrically,
the region that normally
control leg muscles,
anatomically intact after
a spinal cord injury,
but disconnected from the brain.
And it was quite amazing
because as early as you
applied the stimulation,
the animal would start
stepping automatically
on the treadmill.
When I met him, I saw the
the mice and rats walking,
and it was fantastic.
The idea was to bring
it to the human being.
I don't think like the average person
knows that this is even
possible right now.
Maybe explain like what you're finding
people are able to do.
If you have a spinal cord injury,
your brain is intact, giving
a command to your legs,
but this command is interrupted
at the level of the injury,
and the idea of the treatment
is to reactivate the disconnected part
of the spinal cord in order
to then activate your legs.
So how do you activate this
part of the spinal cord?
With electricity.
So this is what we call the paddle lead.
It has 16 electrodes as you see here,
eight and eight in parallel.
And we implant this paddle lead
in the dorsal aspect
above the spinal cord.
The electrodes get implanted
on a different part of the spine
depending on what the
patient is trying to do.
Place them on the lower spine,
and you can get the legs moving.
When the first patient
stood up, I don't know,
in my head I'm picturing
everybody like crying and hugging.
What was it like?
Or is it more?
Yeah, you are in Europe.
Yeah.
You have Italian, you
have a lot of emotion,
so there was a lot of bad words.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, but it was a big emotional.
Yeah, it was like, .
In other patients,
the electrodes are placed
higher up on the spine
to help regulate blood pressure,
a less obvious but equally
life-changing effect.
My name is Julie.
I'm 23 years old, and I'm an archeologist.
One year and a half ago,
we had a major car accident
in Serbia and I basically broke my neck.
My condition of blood
pressure issues got so bad
that I was basically like
what you guys were looking for
in the study.
And then we came here and I got implanted.
Yeah, I did not know that
blood pressure issues
are something that's quite common
with this type of injury, but it is.
Without, I mean my
blood pressure is so low
that I'm basically just
stuck in bed all the time.
Even just sitting up in a wheelchair,
it's like running a marathon.
Yeah.
It also has a huge impact
on my mental state of mind.
Yeah.
Without the stimulation,
there is so little oxygen
circulating in my brain
that there is not much
joy in life, let's say.
And then when you turn it on,
it's like back to some
sort of normal level,
and it's just the increase of energy,
being able to breathe and
speak at the same time.
I'm able to make plans to travel
to just have a more positive
outlook on life in general.
Now it's still a little bit of a warmup.
Michel is a young man who
had a motor bike accident
a few years ago already
with a complete motor
and sensitive paralysis.
Okay.
And this is a real athlete.
He trained a lot with us,
and he's using this technology
every day, many hours.
I have two buttons, one per side.
Every time I press, I send
the signal to the tablet,
and I have the movement, I make the step.
The walk may be strained,
but it's good enough
that Michel is mostly able
to get around without a wheelchair.
And the implant lets him do
other kinds of exercises too.
He has a program that just target
the region of the spinal
cord involving trunk muscle.
So he is uploading the program.
Just pressing a button I have a six pack.
Oh wow.
I need this program.
Rather fantastically, Michel,
whose legs were completely paralyzed,
has regained a tiny amount
of homegrown organic muscle control.
Something in my body is changing.
I now it is getting some
twitch on the muscles.
Okay.
Under the region.
Yeah.
We know that the residual nerve fibers,
cause there are always
some residual nerve fibers,
they'll grow because of the stimulation
and that improve the communication
to the point that they can regain control
over the paralyzed muscles.
The doctors don't know
how far the regrowth
of nerve fibers can go.
With only a handful of
patients implanted so far,
there's still much to learn,
but there are other ways
that Jocelyne and Grégoire
want to push the tech forward.
They have started to combine
brain computer interfaces
with the spinal implants.
That is to say they're putting electrodes
in the brain and on the spine
and having them communicate.
This lets patients simply
think about actions
like walking or swimming
and have their bodies
pick up on their desires.
What do you think?
You going brain implants?
I took with my hair.
Two years ago, Onward went public
and raised $100 million dollars.
They're still in the clinical trial phase
with much of this work,
but are on track to
become the first company
to commercialize these kinds of implants.
The hope is to get them
covered by insurance
and accessible to the millions
of people around the world
living with spinal cord injuries.
Every time I see him progressing,
each time I see him, it's very rewarding.
On the other hand, it's very frustrating
because I would like to see 1000, Michele.
It's very cool, man.
I can tell you're very focused.
Every day, I want even more.
Every time I want more.
As Werner Herzog said,
"The fountain is life
or a tourist attraction.
"It's totally up to you."
This is Geneva's fountain hotspot.
It's beautiful, ejaculatory,
everything you could want in a fountain.
Do you want me to do a straighter one?
I'm not going to lie, I
didn't exactly do my homework
on the touristy bits of Switzerland.
Is this Lake Geneva?
Let's find out.
I'm not getting a clear answer on that
but we're going to go with it.
It's nice as you can see.
But me, I'm just here for the brains.
And in cities like Zurich and Lausanne,
you can find some of the
world's brain research hotspots.
Here neuroscience and computer
science mix promiscuously
with wildly creative results.
For example, this lab full
of rodent twitch streamers
run by animal research
superstar Mackenzie Mathis.
So it sounds a little bit far out,
but we really teach
mice to play video games
and use little joysticks like pilots.
But the cool thing about this is,
is that we then allow to see
how they learn these different
skills and how they adapt,
and at the same time can
record the neural activity.
And we hope to turn sort
of the lessons learned
in the brain into literally
new AI algorithms.
What are we going to see today?
So today we're going to
take you into the lab
and show you some of the latest
gen video games for mice.
They're kind of in a freely moving world,
but all the world is a screen,
and it changes based on
their real time movements.
This is the VR world.
Exactly.
Are we going to put a mouse in here?
We're going to put a mouse in here.
Okay.
Yeah.
So if I am not mistaken,
this is Anchovy and Barracuda.
So who is that?
This is Anchovy
Anchovy is off.
It's this idea of they're
learning this game.
They're facing challenges
or they're going through this environment.
Yes, exactly.
And it's just what is the brain doing
as they try to like negotiate
that and figure things out?
Yeah, exactly.
What did she do?
She made the things appear
by standing in the middle
and then facing with the right
heading angle at the screen.
Anchovy may be impressive,
but she has yet to enter her final form.
So in order to be able to
measure the neural activity,
what we do for part of the experiments
is to replace the top of the
skull with a glass plate.
Behold, mouse brains
This mouse had this surgery,
and now she's learned to play this game.
I think the mouse treadmill's so funny.
The mice themselves are
genetically engineered
such that in some neurons,
their neurons actually glow green.
And then you can capture
this with a camera
and then we can extract sort
of the regions of interest
from all these different neurons
and then analyze them in relation
to the actual gameplay or the
actual behavior of the animal.
The ultimate goal is to
turn these mousy thoughts
into data.
Mackenzie wants to record
how brains function
in certain situations and
use those insights to inform
and shape AI systems.
In other words, she
wants to use real brains
to make better artificial brains.
We hope by trying to understand
like literally the algorithm
or the computations,
like are they using arithmetic?
Is it calculus?
Like what are they doing?
And how can we potentially
take those sort of computations
and then test them in new AI algorithms?
So that's the general idea.
Mice are nice and all,
but they're not the only critters
having their brain scanned
here at Swiss Research Institutes.
These are our fly stocks.
So each and every single
one of these fly vials
contains flies that are
genetically distinct.
Meet Ana Marija Jaksic,
the queen of the flies.
We normally have to anesthetize them
because they're flies, they fly.
So we have to kind of
keep them nice and still.
Your objective is to find
males versus females.
Let's do that.
The male is the dark butt, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's correct.
That's right?
Yeah, yeah, you're a natural.
So our basic question in our lab is
in complex environments
you have to have to
learn where things are.
You have to memorize things.
So we're trying to kind of
recreate these situations
for the flies, and we try to
evolve cognition in flies.
So you're trying to
make super smart flies.
Yeah, exactly.
Fly masterminds.
What could go wrong?
Something like this, yeah.
So you breed smarter and smarter flies.
You get them to do these tasks.
Exactly.
You find which ones perform the best.
Take those, breed them again.
Exactly.
It's basically fly eugenics.
But how do you separate
the Fleinsteins from the Flimbeciles?
With a fly-Q test, of course.
So right now we are conditioning
flies to pick one color
in a set of two or three colors.
They're picking between green or blue.
Every single fly at the
very end of the experiment
will get a a learning score.
We get rid of the 10%
of the worst performers,
and we take the majority of the flies, so.
I see, okay.
As she breeds generation
after generation of bugs,
Ana Marija hopes to learn
about the relationship
between genes and intelligence.
We can track specifically
what are the genes that are being selected
for cognitive behaviors.
How specifically does
the brain actually change
in its structure?
And all of this we can
actually use for wet wear.
So instead of using physical chips,
we can use biological
chips like neurons itself
to actually power our computers someday.
I see, yeah.
In the future, you know?
Yeah, I think every scientist
I've interviewed for this show so far
just about is like trying
to make AI smarter.
Yeah, yeah.
And better.
It's the ultimate kind of goal
to see how to produce ourselves, right?
Yeah.
In many ways, even the
tiniest corporeal brains
are smarter than our best AIs.
So the researchers here think
that studying these
creatures is our best shot
at creating things like
highly capable robots.
If we could build an AI that
could do what a mouse does,
I think that would be a
huge feat for humanity.
Maybe within 10 years
we could have, you know,
mini mice robots.
Not that we want that for
humanity, but conceptually, right?
We want something like an embodied agent
that can act in the world
and very adaptively change its behavior.
I just pictured like New
York full of robotic AI mice
and was horrified.
That would be pretty scary.
Of course, the brain I want
most to understand is my own.
So I decided to volunteer
as a test subject.
Okay, friends ready to
go down the rabbit hole?
This lab at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology
is run by an eccentric
psychonaut named Olaf Blanke.
He invited me to try an experiment
that's meant to induce the
feeling of a ghostly presence.
Real talk, I'm a little bit scared,
but first let's get existential with Olaf.
So I've been interested
for a long time in the self
and how it is related to our body,
how the brain actually
represents our body.
How are my hands represented in my body?
How is your brain representing your body?
What gives us the conscious
experience of being someone?
Of being a person?
We are looking at
something very perceptual.
We call it a minimal self.
And we think that this minimal
self is crucial for feeling
that I'm feeling right now
sitting in front of you
here talking to you.
So this very like basic
fundamental connection
between mind and and body.
Exactly, so it's an active brain process.
Yeah.
On a millisecond by millisecond basis,
we have to generate this representation
where we are in space,
and it better be here
where my body is located.
We take this for granted,
but this process is
happening all the time.
Yes, I think much of.
Well, except when it isn't.
Think out-of-body experiences
or feeling a ghostly presence in the room.
Anomalies that Olaf first encountered
while treating patients
with neurological disorders.
They were talking, for example,
that before they have an epileptic seizure
they may have an out of body experience.
Okay.
And of course they didn't use that term,
but they were saying, yeah, listen, Olaf.
It was strange.
I was, I had the sensations
for about a couple of seconds
that I was above myself
or it could have been a
presence hallucination
or a ghost sensation.
I remember one patient in
particular who told me,
well, there's somebody just
at arm length behind me.
And whenever she got up and
moved, that person moved along.
Okay.
So very strange.
So is your theory that
stories of ghosts over time,
this is kind of where it all comes from
is people having these feelings?
Yeah, so,
if you want a naive, quick
response, yes, that's what it is.
It turns out these sensations
are a common symptom
of Parkinson's disease.
So the presence hallucination,
feeling somebody behind
you that is not there,
that you can't hear, that you can't see,
50% of Parkinson patients will have that
Naturally, this inspired Olaf
to figure out how to
induce these hallucinations
on demand using VR and robotics.
So you will be sitting on this chair,
and your main task will
consist in moving this robot.
Okay.
Can you confirm
you're in a dark environment right now?
Yeah, it's, yeah, nothing it's just black.
Oh, there you are.
You can see that he is
immersed inside a virtual room
which is mimicking this
real experimental room.
So it's a recreation of the room in 3D.
As I move my hand to
poke a virtual avatar,
a robot behind me gave
me a corresponding poke.
It's all meant to confuse
your brain so much
that you start to sense the
presence of another being
while Olaf studies what's
going on in your brain.
Thank you.
Okay, perfect.
That was weird.
Sometimes I sort of
thought I was doing it,
and then sometimes it really
felt like almost like an animal
or something was kind of kneading in my.
The sensation for me
was not all that strong,
but that's partly the point.
Since Parkinson's patients
are more susceptible to
the illusion than others,
the experiment could function
as a kind of early warning
system for the disease.
With a robotic device,
we don't need to wait for the symptoms.
We don't need to wait for the
patient to have Parkinson's,
but we could expose people
to this much earlier
if they have other risk factors.
And if they would be part of
this very elevated sensitivity,
we could team up, for
example, with companies
starting very early
neuroprotective therapies
trying to delay the onset of Parkinson's
or cure Parkinson's.
What an exciting time between VR,
brain computer interface,
artificial intelligence.
I mean, it must be like exhilarating
to have this intersection.
Sure, no, so no, it's absolutely,
so I think what is
special about this time,
I think, when I started
neuroscience was neuroscience.
You know, philosophy was philosophy,
and certainly engineering was engineering.
There was always an interest
in medical applications.
But what is really amazing happening now
is it doesn't matter anymore, right?
Yeah.
We're all working on similar problems
and issues and want to resolve this.
The brain is, I think, by definition
something that's fascinating for everyone,
and it needs expertise
from all these domains,
I think to have even a chance
to understand small parts of it.
80 years after Hoffman's psychedelic ride
Switzerland's brain research
complex is still going strong,
but the mysteries of the
mind remain mysterious.
We still don't really know
how billions of neurons
firing creates a thought
or how to fully restore
a broken connection
between mind and body.
Researchers here will be on this quest
for a long time to come, but
it's a journey worth taking,
and I'm excited to see what's next.
That is, as long as it's not AI rodents
bent on our destruction.